hey everybody how's everybody doing
awesome man
so a hundred thousand people a day watch
my wine show Wine Library TV and it's 38
minutes on average of me sitting at a
table and drinking three wines which is
about as uninteresting of a concept as I
can think of especially since I spend at
least 15 minutes talking about the New
York Jets and I and I always wonder why
why would so many people listen of
course the content is good I know a
shitload about wine and clearly I'm
shockingly handsome so I understand that
works for me
but at the end of the day I think where
we're going is something I called the
Thank You economy
you see crush it up there that was a
book I wrote that did extremely well and
I spent $0 on traditional marketing to
make it one of the bigger selling books
of last year and I did it by using the
Thank You economy that's what I want to
talk to you about usually I have an hour
so eight minutes or nine minutes is
tough so I'm gonna spit it out
rapid-fire I believe firmly and
especially in the luxury category where
a lot of you guys live that we are
living through the humanization of
business the reason that so many people
watch my show buy my books why I am one
of the top 300 followed people on
Twitter and by far the least famous or a
brand recognized is because I out cared
everybody see everybody in this room and
everybody in this world right now is
thinking about what they're gonna say
what's the content calendar what's our
personality what is our voice and the
problem is is that we're massively stuck
in talking too much what we have an
amazing ability to do today and never
did before is actually listen in night
in 2007 I spent 13 hours a day while I
was running a 60 million dollar year
wine business so this became my real job
not what was distracting me 13 hours a
day using a site called summize dot-com
summize was bought by Twitter a couple
years ago and is now the backend of what
search.twitter.com is it is firmly
my belief that one of the most powerful
important sites on the Internet today is
search Twitter
the reason so many people how many
people here think Twitter is stupid
raise your hand be honest not bad how
many people just don't get it what the
fascination with Twitter is the fact
that matter is the reason so many people
don't why hands go up like that is
because everybody wants to know what to
say what am I supposed to say
Twitter so stupid why would who cares if
I'm eating a pizza or walking my dog
nobody but where Twitter gets powerful
and where the opportunity in this new
world where we have so much data is is
we can listen I spent 13 hours a day
searching Chardonnay Merlot Pinot Grigio
Bordeaux she known Pinot Gris and
actually cared enough to answer and not
say hey go to wine library calm and buy
it or hey watch this video I just did on
Syrah I just said here's your answer
this is what you need and started
building context of an actual
relationship see what's really
interesting to me is I firmly believe
going forward that our grandparents are
more suited to be successful and social
than we are because we're going back to
small-town rules marketing is about to
get really [ __ ] hard it's about to
get really one-on-one and I think that's
a very important thing that people need
to understand it's no longer super easy
to just stack it high and let it fly you
can't just pound down the message when
you hear things like Eric Schmidt from
Google say more content is created now
in 48 hours than was from the beginning
of time until 2003 it starts putting
things in perspective beginning of time
- 2003 every 48 hours same amount there
is an obscene amount of stuff being
thrown at us and the things that are
gonna filter through are not always
going to be the things that are the most
creative I sit in green rooms like this
and in conferences I start a consulting
company we have clients like you know
Campbell's and PepsiCo the National
Hockey League and everybody's trying to
figure out how to make it happen how are
we gonna do it right we all think we're
so damn smart we're gonna market it and
figure it out the reality is is the
consumers [ __ ] radar is so much
better
that anybody in this room or in this
game realizes and now that we can
actually hear from them and see it we're
starting to understand that to me what
I'm passionate and fascinated about is
how in the world would you allow this
scenario to happen you're sitting at a
coffee shop and the person sitting right
next to you and let's say new york-style
they're damn close and they're talking
about your brand are you gonna say thank
you or interject maybe you know
especially if they're saying let's say
something positive instead of something
negative you may actually say oh cool
thanks so much for liking vitaminwater I
work throwing water blah blah blah the
fact that matters that's happening
online thousands if not millions of
times a day around brands and we stay
silent I am shocked that brands in 2011
are going to put themselves in a
position where they're not gonna thank
people for saying the nice things they
say publicly to their entire social
graph I'm blown away that we don't
recognize that what we need to do now is
take advantage of this insane phenomenon
which is this six years ago if I'm
sitting and watching a Jets game with my
buddy and I drink a Bud Light and say
you know what this Bud Light Lime really
sucks I'm never ordering this again two
minutes later my doorbell rings I come
and open hey I'm John from Bud Light
we're really sorry you don't like the
lime flavored flavor but you know please
try our Bud Light extreme two things
would happen one I would punch him in
his face two I would move we would never
understand why we could have a
relationship with a brand that would be
spooky creepy and it still is for many
but if you're not paying attention to
the fact that we have now conditioned
ourselves as humans to actually have
relationships with logos you're missing
out on something that is really emerging
and is extremely powerful and now it's
gonna come down to do businesses have
the ability to be human do we strategize
for sales or do we actually give a [ __ ]
and the reality is I firmly believe that
most people just want to sell [ __ ] and
I'm really curious what happens when
people understand that the battleground
will be caring because in a world where
word-of-mouth is going to dominate it's
gonna get real interesting in a world
where 10 years ago
the biggest Yenta on the upper east side
has a negative or positive experience
she can only do so much damage in
telling her social graph now the most
Awkward weird
introvert that lives in Iowa that lives
in his mom's basement can tell more
people and that starts impacting our
business and what I'm really curious
about is do people recognize how much of
an eyeball shift an engagement shift has
happened
what I'm curious about is in 2011 are
you just gonna buy a TV ad and run
billboards and not extend the story into
social the ability to play ping-pong
with traditional and social is here to
not extend the story and collect the
data is just a massive miss and I think
it's really funny I think people are
obsessed that you know old media is dead
or you know a lot of people in my space
for short routes on you know magazines
or commercials or radio to me
super viable still and more importantly
the creative within them is dead we're
not creating scenarios to allow us to
extend the story to collect the data
when Reebok hockey runs a commercial
during the Winter Classic and then they
say if you want to see the rest of this
video go to our Facebook page and they
pick up 70,000 fans in 30 seconds they
now have the data of those 70,000 people
forever and gonna leave you with one
last thought because I had to go
helter-skelter here please promise me
one thing if nothing else please have a
very very substantial strategy for
mobile in 2011 anybody who doesn't
recognize the power of mobile is really
going to be hurt the consumption numbers
are scary I'm sure you all saw what
happened with Facebook places and deals
that is has just enormous implications
we are living through the biggest not
one of the biggest we don't live in
through the biggest culture shift in the
way we interact with each other and
consume media and my opinion because the
Internet is only 15 years old
we've only been 15 years since AOL
spammed your actual mailbox and sent you
a CD this is a few seconds I mean the
internet hasn't had sex yet and it's
dominating
my belief is because the internet is so
young and we think so fast that we are
grossly under estimating how early this
is and how large the impact is and until
your businesses become humans and have
relationships create true context with
users and extend those for the marathon
instead of the quarterly report sprint
it's gonna be difficult to succeed going
forward I love everybody bye-bye oh by
the way I know we have lunch and make
sure you pay attention to Greg showed
the pinot noir i selected is gonna blow
your [ __ ] face off